- We have a video of you working
on Firefly Lane from home.
So, let's see the video.
- [Director] Are you ready?
- [Kathrine] Mm-hmm.
- [Director] Action.
- Oh, yes. Yes.
(audience laughs)
- I mean, take that one Harry Met Sally
or Seven from Friends.
So, the kids are used to shouting
coming from the other room
now, so you're in the clear.
(Kelly laughs)
- You gotta wonder what
they were thinking?
- Yeah, you can just now
always say you were working.
Oh, we were working on a project.
(Kelly laughs)
- Yeah, no.
My Adalaide said to me
the other day that she
and Naleigh give each other a look
when they hear something weird.
And I said, "What do you mean by weird?
What do you hear that's weird?"
And she was like, "well, you know,
if we hear shouting or you
and dad laughing really hard
or, you know..."
(Kelly laughs)
"There's always something
about you grabbing Dad's butt."
And I was like, "Okay."
- [Kelly] Okay. (laughs)
- Maybe we should be more
quiet about these things.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
Or show them how a fun
relationship sounds.